il y a un enchaînement de choses qui
fait que on peut se poser la question
comment comment aujourd'hui dans ce pays
on peut se lever le matin et se prendre
une balle dans la tête le soir c'est pas
un film contre les flics parce qu'il y a
des bons flics il y a des mauvais flics
il y a toutes sortes de gens différents
donc on peut pas on peut pas englober
les choses même vous n'avez pas la haine
des flics
quand ils viennent il y a des bons il y
a des mauvais flics j'avais une des
mauvais flics quoi on parle de bavures
policières et il faut il faut le faire
avec recul parce que c'est pas c'est pas
simple c'est pas des histoires qui
arrivent c'est
il y a des gens qui payent et qui payent
les pots cassés c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
toujours des c'est toujours les mêmes
mecs qui se prennent des balles mais
c'est jamais la faute et jamais que d'un
côté j'avais un grand-père qui disait ce
qu'il faut c'est choqué le bourgeois
c'est vrai que c'est vachement c'est
quelque chose de d'intéressant à faire
parce que c'est c'est les gens qu'il
faut qu'il faut qu'il faut réveiller il
faut réveiller leur confiance si c'est
possible bon on risque ce n'est qu'un
film donc on peut pas faire c'est pas
non plus la révolution